So now you can see the reaction’s really
going and it’s really exothermic,
we’re forming aluminium triiodide, and the
exotherm is actually heating
and starting to sublime off the excess iodine
which you can see coming
off as this really nice purple plume.
Iodine is this beautifully-coloured element.
It has this beautiful purple
colour. If you put it in solution, the colour
of the solution varies
depending what you dissolve it in. If you
dissolve it in water, it’s a sort-of
dirty brown colour. If you dissolve it in
an organic material like
chloroform or carbon tetrachloride it is a
beautiful purple colour.
Iodine is halide, a halogen element from the
far right-hand side of the
periodic table and it's strongly oxidising
in nature. Likes to nick electrons
off other atoms, so what we’re going to do
is we are going to do a
reaction with iodine, and today we’ve ground
some iodine. So it’s
normally found from chemical suppliers as
really nice large crystals. But
what we want to do as a reaction with it,
well we need to make sure that
the surface area of the iodine is really,
really large so that all of it can
react very very quickly with the other component.
Iodine also occurs quite widely in nature
and is absolutely essential to
life. If you don’t have iodine, your thyroid
gland, which is a small gland
that controls development of all sorts of
things in your body, doesn’t
operate properly. Nowadays, iodide is added
to table salt in countries like
the UK and most other developed countries
so nearly everybody has
enough iodine. In the old days iodine had
to be got from the
environment and usually from the spray from
the sea that was blown
across the land, and so in Nottingham, which
is really near the centre of
England a long way from the sea, or relatively
long way from the sea,
there were serious illnesses caused by people
not having enough iodine.
So-called goiter, which caused a swelling,
the thyroid gland gets bigger,
and this used to be called Derbyshire neck
this unpleasant illness,
because it happened in this area of Nottingham
and Derbyshire.
So what we’re going to do is that we are
going to mix it now with
another element and that element is aluminium.
So aluminium has
electrons to give away. Iodine’s gonna nab
‘em. Going to see some
oxidation chemistry in the formation of a
new compound, which is
aluminium triiodide. It’s a really nice chemical
reaction. But the way that
we do it is that we mix the two together and
we have to add water which
acts a bit like solvent and also the oxygen
in the water activates the
iodine so that it becomes more strongly oxidising
and then hopefully we’ll
see the new reaction. So I’m going to just
put some out into this small
vessel.
You can see this development effect of iodine
really well that if you had
tadpoles, baby frogs, they don’t develop
their legs and turn into frogs
unless there is iodine in the water.
The other component in this reaction is aluminium,
ok; and we’re using
very, very finely powdered aluminium. Not
foil or not a rather large
lump. This has been especially powdered for
us, so again it has a very,
very high surface area.
One of my favourite chemical equations is
‘tadpoles plus iodine goes to
frogs’. So you can see the aluminium and
the iodine mixed within this
solid mixture. Now still, these two components,
these two elements they
are still held away from one another they
can’t react. So what we need
to do is add a small amount of water, which
actually acts like a solvent
but actually activates the iodine and then
we’ll wait and see what
happens with the chemical reaction.
Iodine can be used as a disinfectant, in fact
chlorine can be as well, but
solution of iodine is often used when people
have cuts. So if you cut
yourself, fortunately I haven’t any cuts
at the moment, you can paint on
iodine and because of its rather red colour
it made cuts often look much
worse. Children would come home from school
and their whole hand
would be red and this would cause some excitement
at home but it is
quite an effective antiseptic.
Water: just take a small amount and add it
to the reaction. So you can
see it’s starting to go now the chemical
reaction because we are seeing
the excess iodine subliming in the form of
a vapour. Now if we go in
close we can hear it fizzing because this
is actually an oxidation reaction
and the formation of the new aluminium triiodide.
Now I’m going to just
mix this slightly to try and increase the
rate of the chemical reaction
slightly. So now you can see the reaction’s
really going and it’s really
exothermic, we’re forming aluminium triiodide,
and the exotherm is
actually heating and starting to sublime off
the excess iodine which you
can see coming off as this really nice purple
plume. Now deep inside the
reaction now you can see the exothermic or
the energy coming out and
starting to cause a flame. Really, really
nice, really rapid chemical
reaction: really beautiful. So we’re forming
aluminium triiodide here
which again is a very, very delicate compound;
quite reactive in itself.
So you can see now the really nice new crystalline
material. So, sadly,
we’ve managed to stain Stig’s fume cupboard.
All of this really nice
iodine forming a very fine layer across this
fume cupboard.
What do you think about that?
Looks like a thorough cleaning job coming
to be honest.